hey guys I think it's my brother Skyler
right here and I'm a genius which is
only a ten minute walk away program is
like so worked here all this time today
we're going to take you on are you I'll
show you all the sheep that we normally
get very excited this is like a
Taiwanese classic combo telephone
literal translation is big sausage
wrapped around small sausage Wow
[Music]
the baked sausage is made of glutinous
rice the sausage on the inside is your
normal meat sausage so it's essentially
a double sausage look at that garlic
good
crispy on the outside and tender on the
inside and the garlic there's like
either liver also the rice is really
good two three filling
this is like Asian hotdogs it's still
crowded people why do you look so
miserable
have a taste of your own medicine you're
insane
week week it's chicken and cheese look
at that Oh Jews I didn't even know it
makes you think about your favorite
they have thin creeks and then they have
freshly shaved peanut
which they sprinkle on followed by two
scoops of ice tea ice cream you can
choose to put on cilantro if you want
how excited are you
no happy
[Music]
- not the hair of the left ear - max
panting low
we found a classic County's Fried
Chicken Picatta big gigantic piece of
chicken you used to love eating this
there's different spices we're going
with the original
chicken piece you can choose to have it
cut but we're doing it the og way you
away the patty-pan wheelchair
Michigan baby
your childhood favorite it's so big it's
huge that is how big it is
batter is just right it's like not a lot
but it's insane don't talk with your
mouth full
powder big-ass
trying to find a trash can't find one
this is the dragon beards candy I made
[Music]
masters at work just for funsies
this is the real deal that's so pretty
Keo
this is so hard to buy nowadays
it's a bit on the expensive side but
it's gonna be worth it right city
council oh it's been braised for four
hours on the top side chili
yapping eating with the chili and runny
now as noodles
favorite brownie dude you took which
deep-fried so it's crunchy on the
outside and there's this beautiful shot
the smell
no thank you there I've finished it
alright say five years or anything are
you getting for
this is the most famous stop here which
is pepper beef filling and this really
good you shall be looked at this rain
it's gonna be a long wait what I love
about this place is that they make
everything here at the night market it's
so fresh
how many are you getting
I wish I could eat more I wish had fight
stomach like I'm gonna bring my country
water
[Music]
the super juice
it's always worth the wait it's always
worth the birds that's why it's a family
favorite our mom left us to dance thing
is is freshly made right on the spot
Cara we made it
I don't know how that was a lot of food
it's probably why I gained like ten
pounds every single time come here
coming here in a few days
alright let's go home